I'm in resolute nunavut canada the last
stop on my Arctic voyage it is one of
the most northern and coldest inhabited
places in the world and the only reason
I'm allowed to film here right now is
because we have someone on polar bear
watch there is some evidence of
prehistoric settlement here but this
town didn't exist until 1947 when the US
and Canada built a weather station here
and it wasn't populated until 1953 when
the Government of Canada forcibly
resettled Inuit from northern Quebec
here as part of a power play in the Cold
War the High Arctic relocation is a dark
chapter in Canada's history and the
stories of those who were moved into
appalling conditions a tales best told
by people who were there not some
British tourist there are links in the
description for context and I strongly
recommend you watch them but what I can
talk about is why the 1950s Canadian
government thought it was worth
uprooting people from their homes and
moving them this far north the North
Pole and most of the Arctic Ocean are
international waters there's no land
below the ice so the trees are the same
as the Atlantic or Pacific but unlike
countries further south where it's easy
to say why your coastline ends and the
sea begins up here in the north it's a
little bit more complicated in the 50s
there was an open legal question if no
one lived on these northern islands if
they're not even habitable could they
really be part of Canada particularly
when the United States is sending
hundreds of soldiers up here to stake a
claim to shore up the defense against
Soviet Russia the shortest route from
Russia to America for aircraft carrying
nuclear bombs and later for
intercontinental ballistic missiles was
over the North Pole over here over
resolute and while the Canadian
government were happy to cooperate with
America they were not about to risk
being pushed out the government solution
back then move some people who they
think don't matter and make it clear to
the world this is Canadian territory
look Canadians live here the
repercussions from that still go on
today and so does the argument about
sovereignty up here just for different
reasons because while the Cold War has
ended and missiles will hopefully not be
flying over the North Pole anytime soon
there is now a very different question
climate change means that the Northwest
Passage the once legendary sea route
through the north of Canada
is now theoretically open for shipping a
few months a year the north of Canada is
not just frozen ice that goes all the
way to the pole and most of the maps you
see are really misleading this here is
one of a cluster of islands nowhere near
as big as they look on most maps and if
there's no ice between them it's a
shortcut the Arctic is now a possible
route between Europe and the west coast
of America
instead of going through the Panama
Canal and that cuts over 4,000 miles off
the journey and the first cruise ship is
already gone through by the time you
watch this it will have gone through and
it's not an old icebreaker without a
hundred people act like I'm troubling
but a massive cruise ship with thousands
of people eight restaurants and a casino
like it or not this this town this this
space here this is part of a tourist
route now now Canada says some of the
Northwest Passage is part of their
territorial waters almost like a big
wide river anyone going through should
be cleared with them should be subject
to Canadian law and perhaps in future
they should pay a tax the US and Europe
they say it's international waters they
can do whatever they want and the
consequences could be serious if this
does become a major shipping route than
sooner or later there's going to be a
major shipping accent particular leaf
climate change brings unpredictable
storms to the ocean here the idea of
more oil being spilled in the Arctic is
worrying a lot of people and a few
decades as the ice melts more channels
open and drilling for oil and gas
becomes possible our next international
battles political or otherwise might be
for the Arctic not just about who owns
it but for its entire future hi I'm Matt
Chris Hatfield this is I'm from Scott
this is Tom Scott over here in the actor
that's hit some generator Arctic that's
all been an incredible experience extra
Conal on and go to the website that's
written you can see all the details and
go see that show messin holdin throw
the truck hey not so bad